down for promised life
there's not much time
you got to be miles away from here
though
where is she follow that North Star if
there are no stars just fall on the
river
listen for them
is your enemy whoa easy now imma
befriended
I don't know if you know how
extraordinary this is but you have made
it 100 miles to Freedom all by yourself
would you like to pick a new name to
mark your freedom
Harriet Tubman
[Music]
you are welcome here anytime
if I'm free my family should be too I
made up my mind I'm going back
you're confident
composed when Trouble Comes you'll be
ready papers says here you're five and a
half feet tall you ain't more than five
feet
[Music]
muscle in my eyebrows that day
I'm back here it ain't safe
freedom
do you know what would happen if you got
caught you got lucky Harriet
I made a disco on my own so don't you
tell me what I can't do
Harriet welcome to the Underground
Railroad
everybody everywhere is looking for you
God don't mean people to own people
find this thief and burn her at the
stake
I will give every last drop of blood in
my veins
into this monster called slavery is dead
ready